parte se encuentra el tiempo t para el
cual la rapidez de la partícula es igual
a 3 así que primero vamos a recordar a
qué se refiere
esta palabra rapidez y bueno la rapidez
es la magnitud de la velocidad así que
si tú tienes por aquí la componente x de
tu velocidad voy a suponer que es esta
de aquí ésta es la componente x de tu
velocidad entonces es la forma en la que
cambia x con respecto al tiempo muy bien
y por acá tenemos la componente i de tu
velocidad voy a suponer que es ésta es
decir la forma en la que cambia ayer con
respecto al tiempo bien entonces la
rapidez es la magnitud de este vector
que estoy dibujando ahorita es la
magnitud de este vector que tengo aquí
entonces cuánto es la magnitud de esto
bueno vamos a usar un teorema de
pitágoras esto va a ser lo mismo
déjame ponerlo así va a ser lo mismo que
la raíz cuadrada
de quién bueno me voy a tomar a la
componente x del vector velocidad o la
forma en la que cambia x con respecto al
tiempo que es la derivada de x con
respecto al tiempo ya esto lo voy a
elevar al cuadra bien ya esto le vamos a
sumar la componente i del vector
velocidad o la forma en la que cambia ya
con respecto al tiempo es decir de g con
respecto al tiempo esto elevado al
cuadrado bien lo único que hice fue un
teorema de pitágoras y esto de aquí es
la rapidez y bueno queremos saber en qué
tiempo la rapidez es igual a 3 así que
vamos a hacerlo me voy a tomar la raíz
cuadrada
y ahora vamos a recordar quién es la
derivada de x con respecto al tiempo eso
lo tenemos acá arriba la derivada de x
con respecto al tiempo está justo aquí
es coseno de t cuadrada y la derivada de
ye con respecto al tiempo es el elevado
a la 0.50 entonces vamos a usar a esos
dos y entonces me quedaría que la
derivada de x con respecto al tiempo es
lo mismo que tomarme el coseno coseno de
t cuadrada
esto a su vez está elevado al cuadrado
ya esto le voy a sumar la derivada de ya
con respecto al tiempo que acabamos de
recordar que era el elevado a la 0.5
ya esto lo voy a elevar al cuadrado lo
voy a elevar al cuadrado bien observa
que esta es la expresión de la rapidez
con respecto al tiempo y lo que nosotros
queremos es averiguar cuando esto de
aquí es igual a 3 porque es justo lo que
nos piden y bueno ahora podría restar 3
de ambos lados y meter todo eso en la
calculadora pero voy a tratar de
simplificar un poco para que sea más
ordenado al meterlo a la calculadora así
que lo primero que voy a hacer es elevar
de ambos lados al cuadrado y me va a
quedar que posee no dt cuadrada dt
cuadrada esto elevado al cuadrado
más bueno y ahora tengo el elevado al
0.5 tema al cuadrado déjame verlo aquí
es elevado a la 0.5 y esto a su vez está
elevado al cuadrado bueno pues esto es
lo mismo que el elevado a la 0.5 t que a
su vez multiplica a 2 estás de acuerdo
esto por la regla de los exponentes y
bueno esto va a ser lo mismo que el
elevado a la t porque dos por un medio
dos por 0.5 es lo mismo que uno entonces
aquí tengo en elevado la t esto va a ser
igual y como lb al cuadrado de ambos
lados aquí en lugar de 3 me va a quedar
9 muy bien y ahora voy a restar 9 para
tener una expresión de la forma
efe de el tema howard fx para meter la
calculadora
igual a cero me va a quedar coseno d
de cuadrada todo esto elevado al
cuadrado más elevado a la t menos 9 es
igual a 0 y ahora si lo que buscamos es
un cierto valor de t y para eso voy a
sacar mi calculadora porque de nuevo en
esta parte del examen ap nos dejan sacar
la calculadora para aproximar el
resultado entonces vamos a irnos a más y
absolver perfecto entonces me pide una
ecuación de la forma 0 igual y aquí le
tengo cero igual a seno de y voy a poner
x elevado al cuadrado ok
cierro paréntesis y todo esto está
elevado al cuadrado así que déjenme
poner que todo esto está elevado al
cuadrado de lujo ya esto le voy a sumar
le voy a sumar
elevado a la equis recuerda que estoy
cambiando la variable t por la variable
x para que lo reconozca la calculadora
elevado a la x ya esto le voy a quitar 9
y esto tiene que ser igual a cero así
que le voy a dar enter perfecto y nos
pide un valor para empezar a buscar
soluciones cerca de ese valor así que
qué te parece si tomamos a ese valor
como 0.25 se me ocurre y entonces le voy
a poner alfa solve y se va a tardar un
poco
pero ya está encontró que la solución de
esta ecuación que tengo aquí es una
equis o bueno en este caso una t que es
aproximadamente en 2.196 así que déjenme
notarlo este tema es aproximadamente
aproximadamente en 2.196 y qué creés ya
con esto hemos acabado el inciso sea de
este problema